[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a japanese action
horror film called tag
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
two buses of schoolgirls are driving
down a highway through the woods
everyone engages in cheerful
conversations while a loner named
mitsuko writes a poem her friends ask
her to let go of the notebook for once
and enjoy the world outside of it
mitsuko bends down to pick up her pen
when a gust of wind attacks the school
buses and slices through them bisecting
everyone else on board when mitsuko
looks up the bus has no roof and her
friends are missing the upper halves of
their bodies moments later a second gust
of wind attacks but mitsuko ducks just
in time to avoid being killed like her
friends when the bus stops she gets off
and runs down the highway through the
upper halves of the people who died a
group of four girls is walking in front
of her she pushes one of them to the
ground saving her life as the other
girls suffer the same fate but only a
moment later the girl dies trying to
save a bunch of cyclers being left alone
again mitsuko runs as far as she can and
reaches a river several dead bodies of
schoolgirls have been washed up on the
bank she cleans her face and changes
into a clean uniform before wandering
around the highway again after hours and
hours of walking aimlessly she reaches
an all-girls school strangely enough the
uniform she changed into matches the
uniform of the school the girls seem to
recognize her mexico doesn't ask them
anything or tell them about the mass
killing that happened earlier she is too
stunned to react suddenly her girlfriend
aki approaches her they have not seen
each other for some time but aki claims
that they have always been going to the
same school when a gust of wind hits
them mitsuko panics and falls to the
ground but the wind does no harm this
time aki picks her up and walks her to
school mexico is beyond confused but she
rationalizes the events of the morning
as a lucid dream she believes aki when
she says that they have always gone to
this particular school when alone in a
classroom mitsuko tells aki about the
wind that killed all of her school
friends and starts to hyperventilate to
help her aki brings her to the window
showing her that the wind is absolutely
safe mexico reaches her hand out and
calms down after feeling it the couple
smile at each other thinking of the
absurdity of the situation aki assumes
that mitsuko has some case of amnesia
but laughs it off following that the
couple meets their group of friends and
decides to skip class for the day the
four of them run to the woods while
laughing and playing around mitsuko's
mental state is the complete opposite of
what it was a few hours ago she forgets
everything about her past life
dismissing it as a dream the group stops
to catch a breath upon reaching a
riverbank aki and mexico look at each
other and fall deeper in love mitsuko
then tells the other girls about her
dream one of them thinks she must have
entered a parallel universe sometime
this morning but the others assume she
is only bluffing then they notice a
mattress on the ground nearby and use
the pillow to fight playfully as the
feathers fly all around the girls look
at each other in admiration mexico
notices a lesbian couple standing nearby
watching them with a smile the mattress
and pillows must have belonged to them
but they disappear before mexico can
inquire a girl comments that if they
want their reality to change they must
do something unexpected
and out of the ordinary she follows by
flashing her underwear to them as the
girls laugh her words seem to be of high
importance to mexico as she thinks about
them deeply a while later the girls
returned to the school mitsuko and aki
are in the classroom when mitsuko
notices a pillow on the floor as she
picks it up the teacher starts firing at
them with a machine gun everyone
including aki is killed in the incident
except for mitsuko the teacher says this
is the punishment for them skipping
class she is about to kill mexico as
well but two of her other friends come
to her rescue and help her escape they
are also killed in the process but
before dying the girl from earlier tells
mexico to go wild if the situation calls
for it mitsuko and the remaining girls
run outside the school while still being
fired on by the teachers most of them
die but somehow five of the girls make
it outside suddenly the deadly gust of
wind kills the others leaving mexico
alone yet again before dying the girls
tell mexico that it is all up to her now
while being followed by the wind mitsuko
runs for several minutes before reaching
a town with people a crowd of people is
walking down the street but she pushes
them aside and continues running she
only stops upon reaching a police
station and meeting a lady officer the
officer initially thinks mitsuko is a
maniac because she refuses to speak and
only points in a direction but suddenly
the cop calls her keiko when mitsuko
looks into a mirror she is shocked to
see that she has turned into an entirely
different person the cop turns out to be
keiko's friend tomoko who is excited
about keiko's wedding happening in a few
hours keiko who was a different person
only seconds ago is confused out of her
mind she cannot think straight and
allows tomoko to do whatever she wants
they get into a car to the chapel where
she is getting married the morning has
been a rollercoaster ride for her but it
only gets wilder when a bunch of women
follow their car as if caico is a
celebrity they all express how excited
they are about the wedding at the chapel
many other women surround and welcome
her upon reaching the changing room she
is shocked to see aki getting ready for
the wedding she can almost not believe
her eyes as her mind goes blank she
tries asking her what is going on but
aki secretly whispers to her to keep
quiet for a while she also promises to
explain everything later revealing that
she knows something that keiko doesn't
following that keiko is dressed up in a
wedding gown as the girls gush about how
handsome the bridegroom is keiko
suddenly realizes that she cannot marry
a man when she is in love with aki aki
notices her panicking and makes the
other girls leave the room for some
privacy once they are alone she calls
keiko by her real name and urges her to
do as told keiko still doesn't know
what's going on but she trusts aki
enough to do what she says after she
gets ready a group of girls come inside
the room to invite her to the chapel aki
attacks them and kills them all to teach
keiko how to fight before sending her to
the isle she hands keiko a broken glass
to attack anyone who makes her feel
uncomfortable keiko walks down the aisle
with the glass instead of flowers the
guests who are all girls clap and cheer
for her on the other end of the aisle is
an upright coffin that contains her
groom suddenly the guests start making
inappropriate gestures and taking their
clothes off they mock keiko and push her
towards the coffin when it opens it is
revealed that her future husband is a
disgusting creature with a pig's head
and a man's body the crowd forces her to
kiss him but instead keiko uses the
glass to stab him in a fit of rage she
also kills some of the girls around her
akki comes in at the right time to save
her but they are stopped by a duo of
teachers from the previous school they
fight the duo and manage to run outside
the church aki gets busy distracting the
teachers while keiko continues running
until she is stopped by a girl in a
tracksuit the girl calls her izumi and
invites her to a marathon keiko gets a
look at her face in the mirror and is
surprised to see that she is yet again
transformed into someone else she is now
izumi a star marathon runner who
everyone is fond of a massive crowd
cheers for her as she runs alongside her
friends her friends revealed that she
has always been a good runner ever since
middle school izumi has no clue what
they are talking about but by now she
doesn't even want to know the answers
soon she starts to enjoy herself and
sees that her friends from school are
running alongside her but then the pig
room and the teachers start to chase her
behind the girls ask izumi to be brave
because she is the only one who can
escape this world izumi runs faster than
ever and eventually reaches a cave a
schoolgirl finds her and brings her to a
group of several girls like her who
stand creepily with their hair covering
their faces the girl then tries to kill
izumi claiming that if she doesn't die
everyone else will aki arrives just in
time to save her girlfriend she then
asks izumi to repeat the words i am
mitsuko when izumi does as told she
returns to her original form as mexico
as the last step to escape this world
mitsuko has to pull on two strings
coming out through aki's wrist that will
cut her in half she doesn't want to hurt
the person she loves the most but aki
forces her to pull on the strings as a
result she is sliced in half and mitsuko
enters the real world she ends up in a
restaurant where the first male
characters in the movie are seen on
walking further in she sees a bunch of
perverted men looking at a poster of her
izumi and keiko it turns out that she is
in a lewd city called men's world filled
with only men who enjoy a violent 3d
survival video game called tag the only
controllable characters in the game are
mitsuko izumi and keiko all three of
them being her a man recognizes mitsuko
and tells her that she is in the future
mitsuko passes out and awakens in a
cave-like place where all the characters
of the game are showcased like
mannequins while wandering around she
comes across an old man playing a game
on his tv he reveals that she is 150
years ahead in the future when she was
in high school a long time ago she was a
person that he admired after she died he
took her and her friend's dna and made
clones of them for his 3d game for men's
entertainment a younger version of the
old man appears and gets naked asking
her to come to bed with him the old man
discloses that the final stage of the
game is the fulfillment of his deepest
wish to get intimate with her the man is
about to touch her when she remembers
the words of her friend who asked her to
do something out of the ordinary to get
out of the illusion she is in mitsuko
takes the advice and attacks the man
screaming at him to stop playing with
girls like toys she rips one of the
pillows and the white feathers turn red
from her anger at last she snatches the
old man's cane and commits the
unthinkable to his shock since her death
was never a part of the game in the
final scene mitsuko awakens alone in a
field of white snow
she registers that it is all over now
meaning that she will never have to be
trapped in the game again
although the movie seems bizarre and
meaningless half of the time it is a
metaphor for mexico's homosexuality and
the struggle she faces as a woman in
japan each of the three different girls
represents a female struggling with
different but interrelated problems
mitsuko is a high school girl who is in
love with another girl the scene where
they see the mattress in the middle of
the woods depicts how gay women are
stranded by society similarly keiko is a
woman who is forced to marry a man she
doesn't love hence she sees him as a
disgusting pig who only wants one thing
from her then there is izumi a talented
and determined girl but she is running
from the pig denoting some sort of male
presence is getting in her way of
success in the end the old man making
the girls a character in his game
clearly depicts how society is dominated
by men who take advantage of women and
their problems mexico frees herself from
the bondage only with her own death
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching